voilà un petit peu le dispositif qui va
être décliné lors des différents
articles en ce qui concerne l'index au
signore l'index le Seigneur s'est
effectivement quelque chose je dois vous
le dire je suis pas un grand fan de
l'index au senior il s'agit de faire une
une photographie à publier un certain
moment ça veut dire que une entreprise
qui a beaucoup de seniors c'est pas pour
autant qu'elle aime les seniors c'est
parce que au fil du temps il en est
assis elle a des seniors elle aura un
très bon index puis quand il s'agira de
remplacer ces personnes on va embaucher
des jeunes l'index va se dégrader à
contrario une entreprise qui a beaucoup
de jeunes parce que c'est une entreprise
de technologie de biotechnologie madame
la Présidente et bien ces entreprises là
elles ont que des jeunes pourquoi parce
que les compétences ne sont pas
retrouvées forcément à travers des
seigneurs sont plus volontiers des
compétences plus récentes et qu'il n'y a
que des jeunes qu'il les possèdent donc
elle va avoir un mauvais senior
néanmoins néanmoins nous avons convenu
que il fallait effectivement lancer ce
plan senior et convaincre les
entreprises c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons accepté de reprendre
ce dispositif index senior mais en le
mettant à 300 salariés et non pas des 50
salaires pourquoi parce que 300 salariés
c'est le seuil où il y a ces discussions
au niveau de l'entreprise pour la
gestion prévisionnelle des emplois et
c'est là que l'on peut définir une
politique des seniors et faire en sorte
qu'elle soit clairement déclinée pour
être éventuellement reprises dans le
cadre des index voilà ce qui nous a
animé dans notre réflexion et que je
souhaitais vous présenter
[Musique]